what's going on guys this is Rob and the
force awakens trailer 2 is out right now
and I haven't watched it yet I wanted to
I wanted to do a video like a reaction
video you know to to see to record it
and put it on my youtube channel because
as you guys know I'm a huge fan of Star
Wars Marvel Comics has Star Wars comics
now and and I'm really I'm really
excited to see it so without further ado
let's let's jump me to I know you guys
just want to get straight to the video
so let's just jump into it okay and I'm
already getting goosebumps
I guess that's tattooing
then it's oho my god Wow
I guess there was a Star Destroyer the
force is strong in my family oh my god
Vader my father hasn't
I have it my sister has it because our a
lightsaber holy [ __ ]
the lies that power too
man this has put together so well oh man
look at that x-rays oh yes stormtroopers
of active fighters
who is that
oh my god it looks so good
this looks so amazing holy [ __ ] I'm so
low yes God you guys have no idea how
excited I am
oh man on solo the best character in the
history of the Star Wars series oh man
all right before this next video is toys
we're gonna in that I am oh my god I'm
so excited oh my god I'm so excited for
this movie and it comes out this year it
comes out this year comes on Christmas
we got the Avengers we got ant-man we
got Jessica Jones coming on Netflix
later this year and then we got Star
Wars god this is gonna be the year this
is gonna be the year of nerds comic
nation this is gonna be our year this is
our year all right guys I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and
I'll catch you guys later peace